je pense que c'est un problème alors là
pour le coup c'est un problème féministe
parce que vous avez un certain nombre de
transferts qui colonisent les
territoires féminin est toutefois tout
en prônant une image de la féminité qui
est très traditionnel très conventionnel
et cette image de la féminité nous
l'avons combattu moi je les combattu
tout le temps faim je veux dire
est donc le problème si vous voulez
c'est comme disait martina navratilova
c'est de la concurrence déloyale parce
que les trans femmes donc on la même
force musculaire masculine puisqu'ils
ont pas
puisqu'ils se disent on enfin ceux qui
n'ont pas transitionner jusqu'au bout si
je puis dire ont gardé leur force
musculaire donc vous n'allez pas les
accepter dans des équipes de rugby le
rugby c'est un sport très récent je veux
dire le sport féminin les femmes an à
peine acquis le droit de faire du rugby
et du football etc et donc vous allez
autoriser les hommes à venir dans les
équipes moi je trouve ça quand même très
inquiétant au niveau des droits des
femmes parce que d'un côté on reconnaît
les droits des transgenres à l'identité
de genre mais aux dépens des droits des
femmes aux dépens de leurs du sport
féminin au dépend de beaucoup de choses
comme par exemple les toilettes n'est
présent voyez il n'y a plus aucun
territoire où les femmes sont en travaux
[Musique]